Olá meus amigos minhas amigas sejam
bem-vindos para mais uma live interna na
comunidade
fechada Boa noite Adriana Boa noite
Carlos boa noite
Denise aeni já está em ritmo de carnaval
né Falando nisso fizemos um vídeo sobre
prevenção de problemas de saúde no
carnaval e não tá indo tão bem né Eu
acho que o pessoal percebeu que eu não
sou muito fã de carnaval sei lá bem
vamos lá me deem por favor um retorno se
o áudio está legal tá se o microfone tá
captando bem se vocês estão me ouvindo
bem eu vou dar seguimento Assim que eu
tiver uma confirmação de vocês de que o
áudio tá legal por favor Denise Carlos
Adriana Quem mais esver entrando por
favor me avisem sobre o
áudio para que nós
possamos dar seguimento
talvez vocês tenham percebido que na
semana passada eu tava um pouco rouco
ainda estou um pouco peguei uma virose
Zinha que tá chata de ir embora deniz
obrigado pelo feedback do áudio tá se
puder dar o feedback também Carlos e
Adriana eu agradeceria então peguei aí
uma virose Zinha até que fiquei uns dias
sem na academia por causa
disso ainda tô com
restinho Obrigado pelo aviso Obrigado
pelo aviso Carlos Então temos três
pessoas já falando que o áudio está
legal então vou continuar aqui
tá eu vou falar de uma pesquisa
realizada nos Estados
Unidos um assunto que é muito
preocupante hoje dia que são os
microplásticos então foi descoberto que
há 100.000 moléculas 100.000 moléculas
de nanoplasticos por litro de água
comercializado em garrafas
plásticas e devido ao tamanho dessas
partículas elas podem penetrar no sangue
então são tão pequenas que podem
penetrar no sangue inclusive nas células
e no cérebro então segundo o cientistas
essas moléculas podem ser tóxicas
obviamente né vai nem falar isso isso tá
gerando muita preocupação Então esse
estudo que falou que tem 100.000
partículas nanopartículas de plástico em
1 l de água de garrafa plástica foi
publicado recentemente no periódico
proceedings Of The National Academy of
sciences então nos últimos anos tem sido
uma grande preocupação essa história dos
nanoplasticos ou
microplásticos e atualmente já se sabe
que podemos achar essas partículas no
gelo das calotas polares no solo na água
potável nos
alimentos isso acontece porque o
plástico vai se compondo em partes
menores E essas partículas são
consumidas por todos os organismos seres
humanos outras espécies e há potenciais
efeitos que não são bem conhecidos ainda
tanto no ecossistema quanto na saúde
humana então foram encontradas as Tais
micropartículas ou nanopartículas de
plástico em vários órgãos humanos nos
últimos anos pulmão fígado cérebro então
pros humanos a presença dessas
partículas tem sido uma preocupação
desde um estudo que foi publicado em
2018 que mostrou que
93% de
260 garrafas examinadas de nove países
diferentes querer praticamente quase
todas as garrafas de várias fontes
diferentes estavam tendo esse tipo de
contaminação agora nós temos um método
novo de espectrometria com maior
definição que foi através de esse método
que o trabalho que eu acabei de
mencionar foi feito
Então graças a Esse novo
método Então esse trabalho pode ser
realizado então a originalidade desse
trabalho reside no
interesse pelo mundo pouco conhecidos os
microplásticos
nanoplasticos Então os nanoplasticos são
partículas ainda menores que são da
decomposição dos
microplásticos
então novamente repetindo 1 l de água
continha cerca de 240.000 fragmentos de
plástico detectáveis isso é um número de
10 a 100 vezes mais alto do que
antigamente as estimativas
falavam E aí a definição de micro e
nanoplasticos eu vou dar para vocês os
microplásticos são partículas que vão de
5 mm a 1 micrm
né que é o milionésimo de metro e os
nanoplasticos são menores ainda são
partículas menores que um micrômetro e
são então medidos em bilionésimos de
metro e Diferentemente dos
microplásticos os
nanoplasticos são tão pequenos que podem
passar pelas paredes do intestino Ou
seja é como se fosse o tamanho de
uma molécula alimentar né então passa
pela parede do intestino
e também do pulmão e pode cair
diretamente na corrente sanguínea
alcançando órgãos como coração e Cérebro
bem como feto através da
placenta Então essa área era muito mal
conhecida e tá sendo mais estudada agora
estamos aprendendo mais sobre isso aí os
estudos de toxicidade apenas tentavam
antigamente adivinhar o que poderia
haver nas garrafas d'água agora com
essas novas técnicas aí a gente consegue
ficar essas partículas Muito
pequenas Então esse estudo abre um
Horizonte para observação de um mundo
com qual não tínhamos ainda nos deparado
né Então essa técnica nova de
microscopia de espalhamento raman
estimulado que foi inventada pelo
coautor do estudo Dr Way min um phd
biofísico da Colombia University Então
essa técnica consiste em sondar amostras
usando dois lasers simultâneos ajustados
para fazer Ressoar determinadas
moléculas Então os pesquisadores
testaram três marcas populares de água
engarrafada vendida no
zoa Estados
Unidos analisando partículas de plástico
de até 100 nanômetros
então eles identificaram né esse número
variável de 110.000 a 370.000 partículas
de plástico por litro de nanoplastic na
90% era nanoplasticos que são invisíveis
por técnicas convencionais de imagem né
o restante 10% restantes eram
microplásticos então identificaram que
esses micro eanop plásticos eram de sete
plásticos diferentes tá o tipo mais
abundante é o da poliamida que é um tipo
de
nylon isso provavelmente vem de maneira
irônica dos filtros de plásticos usados
para supostamente purificar a água antes
de ser
engarrafada em segundo lugar está o
talapo de polietileno que é o pet
conhecido
Pet que não é surpreendente já que
muitas garrafas d'água são feitas de pet
e por fim eh os outros plásticos comuns
encontrados foram poliestireno que é o
componente do isopor né cloreto de
polivinila e polimetil metacrilato
né todos eles são utilizados em vários
processos
industriais o que mais preocupante é que
os Sete Tipos de plásticos analisados
pelos pesquisadores representavam apenas
cerca de 10% de todas as nanopartículas
encontradas nas amostras Então os
autores não conseguiram definir os
outros 90% eles não TM nem ideia da
composição dos outros 90% se todos forem
nanopartículas a concentração pode ser
de dezenas de milhões por litro dezenas
de milhões de partículas por
litro então eles foram além da água
engarrafada né Há um vasto mundo de
nanoplasticos a ser estudado segundo o
Dr wake desenvolveu o sistema dos lasers
né esse biofísico observou que em termos
de massa os nanoplasticos são muito
menos numerosos do que os
microplásticos mas não é o tamanho que
importa e sim a quantidade dessas
nanopartículas Porque quanto menores as
partículas mais elas passam pelas
membranas né mais facilmente vão entrar
no
organismo então a equipe planeja estudar
água de torneira que também pode conter
certamente vai conter
microplásticos mas em quantidades
menores do que água engarrafada Então
pessoal vamos evitar água engarrafada em
plástico se você puder comprar água
mineral de vidro se for viável para você
ou ainda você leva a garrafa no vidro da
sua casa do seu filtro doméstico
tá então esse é o primeiro estudo que eu
queria conversar com vocês tá a gente
tem agora agora em termos de
perguntas nós temos 14 perguntas tá que
que vocês querem que eu faça já vai
direto para as
perguntas ou vocês querem que eu
continue falando aí de outras coisas de
artigos interessantes tá o próximo
artigo que eu queria falar com vocês
Caso vocês
queiram É sobre o benefícios da
dietamente Terrâneo por assin intestino
irritável tá
vocês querem que eu fale sobre isso ou
quer que eu vai direto paraas
perguntas vou esperar aqui a resposta de
vocês Adriana tá perguntando de como
desintoxicar do plástico esse
nanoplastic Adriana é uma coisa nova
tá
Ah não sei te dizer como é que seria
essa desintoxicação porque a gente fala
em
desintoxicar por exemplo ch
estrógeno através por exemplo de você
fazer uma
sauna de você fazer atividade física de
usar Grota mas eu não sei se esses
recursos seriam eficientes para
nanoplasticos sinceramente é uma
novidade isso
daí Adriana tá dizendo que tem que que
eu fale do estudo aí da dieta
mediterrânea bem vamos lá tem duas
pessoas já se manifestando que tem
interesse Então vamos mergulhar em um
tema fascinante que é relevante para
todos né que é buscar na melhora da
saúde gastrointestinal e para isso foi
estudado a eficácia da direta
mediterrânea pessoas especialmente que
tem aino intestino irritável então houve
recentemente um estudo controlado e
randomizado
que trouxe luz a essa conexão então vou
falar com vocês e compartilhar os
detalhes sobre esse estudo então se você
sofre alguém que você conhece sofre
intestino irritável
esse material pode
ajudar então foi um ensaio Clínico de
seis semanas em que pesquisadores
investigaram impacto da dieta
mediterrânea em pessoas indivíduos
diagnosticados com sino intestino
irritado o foco estava na viabilidade
aceitabilidade dessa dieta entre os
pacientes além dos principais desob os
sintomas e índice de saúde mental Então
esse estudo contou com a participação de
59 pessoas idade média de 34 anos
maioria eu era do sexo feminino todos
tinham diagnóstico de C intestino
irritável que tinha como sintomas dor
abdominal pelo menos duas vezes por
semana sem outras condições
gastrointestinais ou distúrbios
alimentares e apresentavam sintomas
leves ou moderados de ansiedade
depressão Então nesse grupo os
participantes foram introduzidos a dieta
mediterrânea mas foram dois grupos um
seguiu a dieta mediterrâneas recebendo
orientação à distância de uma
nutricionista Enquanto o outro continuou
com a dieta normal Então teve um curp
controle então foi interessante observar
essa abordagem cuidadosa com os
alimentos que foi feito com orientação
de de perto né de uma
nutricionista então foi observada essa
abordagem cuidadosa com alimentos que
poderiam desencadear sintomas de
intestino irritável como cebolas alho
leguminosas que foram sendo introduzidos
lentamente na dieta então o grupo da
dieta mediterrânea não só mostrou uma
aceitação elevada dessa dieta ou seja
4.3 de C pontos possíveis mas também uma
melor significativa nos sintomas de
intestino irritável mais do que isso o
estudo também revelou uma diminuição nos
sintomas de depressão e ansiedade foi um
benefício adicional muito interessante
Então nós
sabemos que a intestino irritável é um
transtorno gastrointestinal comum que
pode ser muito debilitante para algumas
pessoas tradicionalmente é proposto as
dietas
fodmap são dietas baixas né
em hidratos fermentáveis né o fod map
significa fruto
oligossacarídeos dis sacarídeos
monossacarídeos né álcoois né e polióis
e tem sido uma abordagem padrão para o
manejo dessa doença a dieta fodmap no
entanto a dieta mediterrânea que é
reconhecida por seus inúmeros benefícios
à
saúde é muito conhecida muito famosa
pela redução do risco de doenças
cardiovasculares e melhora da Saúde
Mental agora mostra que pode ser uma
alternativa interessante para indivíduos
com intestino irritável ali aliás eu já
vi casos que melhoraram da intestino
irritável com dieta paleolítica
autoimune e outros casos que nem com
paleolítica autoimune melhorou mas sim
com uma dieta carnívora eu falei dieta
carnívora no
canal tem mais ou menos uns 3 anos mas é
uma dieta muito difícil de seguir na
minha opinião uma das mais difíceis
porque você tem que comer muita
variedade de vísceras né que não é uma
coisa fácil né mas como é que a dieta
mediterrânea Poderia ajudar nac no
intestino irritável o mecanismo exato
ainda não é
conhecido mas sabemos que a dieta
mediterrânea é rica em polifenois com
ácido elágico
azeite de oliva Extra virem e esses
elementos podem oferecer efeitos
antiinflamatórios e moduladores na
microbiota intestinal isso vai
contribuir muito paraa melhoria dos
sintomas do intestino irritável
certo então para vocês aí que tem um
problema ou que conhecem alguém que tem
um problema vale a pena testar essa
dieta que é uma dieta rica em grãos
integrais frutas
vegetais leguminosas e azeite de oliva
extravirgem
ok
Seria bom se vocês pudessem dar algum
feedback do que que vocês acharam dessa
conexão entre diatamente Terrâneo e a
melhoria dos sintomas do intestino
irritável né E se você tem algum
comentário Fale aqui pra gente
tá
eh tem umas perguntas aqui do Eliseu Eu
acho que eu já vou direto para as
perguntas Já estamos com 17 minutos de
Live Boa noite
Estela O Eliseu já tá com Monte pergunta
ao vivo já também deixa eu então já pro
arquivo das
perguntas vamos lá deixa eu até pegar
esse documento das
perguntas deixar ele de um jeito mais
fácil para eu ver
aqui tá E também vou compartilhar a tela
com vocês
também
primeira pergunta do Eliseu na
classificação do tolai Ribeiro os quatro
melhores alimentos são leite materno ovo
óleo de coco quinoa quais os quatro
melhores alimentos na classificação
minha primeira coisa esse essas
alimentos não são absolutos tá pode
ser muito bom para algumas pessoas
e pode ser não tão bom para outras
pessoas por exemplo tem gente que
tem intolerância ao Ovo como é que eu
vou falar que essa pessoa o melhor
alimento é o ovo eu adoro o ovo acho o
ovo maravilhoso Inclusive tem um vídeo
interessante recente aí do doutor
eh David
Berger sobre o ovo que achei muito legal
que tava rebatendo um estudo aí falando
que o ovo causava doença Cardi vascular
que eu acho que uma grande furada né um
estudo mal feito de questionários
alimentares Então se vocês conhecem lá o
canal do doutor
Eh desculpa não é David Berger Eric
Berger né o Eric Berger vão lá assistir
tá em inglês né são para aqueles que
saibam falar inglês mas acho que dá para
você colocar também
a a legenda em português então acho que
essa lista é interessante
sim porém que que eu acrescentaria aí eu
acrescentaria o cacau que é um super
alimento Eu acrescentaria também o
abacate que é um alimento Fantástico
também
[Música]
e azeite de oliva também eu
acrescentaria mas isso é um pouco
arbitrário essas listas tá eu não fica
tão preso nisso daí
não próxima pergunta
Live quinta-feira vou fazer uma live
sozinho de novo e vai ser sobre
hidrogênio molecular tá vai ser esse o
tema da
Live ru Elita você recomenda a vacina
para
Oster Boa
pergunta olha Rita eu acho que essa
vacina pode ser indicada para algumas
pessoas sim mas antes de tentar essa
vacina eu tentaria usar o aminoácido
lisina porque ele muitas vezes já
resolve o problema não tem o és de
repetição se você usa o aminoácido
lisina que é antiviral agora se a pessoa
não melhora e fic tendo crise toda hora
de ERP zosta que é uma doença muito
debilitante eu faria uso da vacina sim
mas eu tentaria lisina
antes quem já teve a doença pode tomar
sim pode ela é recomendado para quem já
teve a doença também
ok e além da lisina que eu já comentei
um tratamento bom também é um antiviral
chamado
valtrex tá que é a Val valaciclovir
que tem pouquíssimo efeito colateral E
tem alguns estudos mostrando que o
valaciclovir pode até melhorar a função
cognitiva de algumas pessoas
contaminadas pelo herp tanto EPS Simplex
quanto EPS zoster que é o vírus do
varicela zoster Ok vamos pro
próximo Fernanda o fenol está sendo
muito utilizado no ramo da estética o
senhor sabe se tem riscos paraa saúde
mesmo usando da forma mais
superficial Porque existe um fenol
profundo já ouvi falar que pode afetar o
fígado eu não usaria viu Fernanda
Sinceramente eu não usaria
eu acho isso uma
furada sabe por
quê o piling de fenol ele pode trazer
riscos à
saúde Ok especialmente se não for feito
corretamente ou em pacientes com
contraindicações eu acho que é um preço
a se pagar pela estética pela vaidade
que não compensa o piling de fenol é um
procedimento agressivo que Penetra
fundamente na pele causando uma
queimadura controlada para estimular a
renovação
celular obviamente só deve ser feito por
médicos especializados e com
monitoramento tem várias
contraindicações por exemplo pessoas têm
problema no rim no fígado no
coração nós sabemos que o fenol é
absorvido rapidamente eliminado
principalmente pelo Zin 75% dele
eliminado por rim e metabolizado pelo fí
25% que pode causar toxicidade nesses
órgãos
Então os especialistas de estética que
utilizam o fenol dizem que a dose
atualmente é 1 quinto da dose
considerada tóxica 1/5 é 20% não é um
número tão pequeno assim
concordam mas eu não usaria tá eu não
usaria mesmo que eles dizem que o a dose
é 1/5 da dose
tóxica Tá além disso o procedimento
Causa muita dor o pós-operatório é
doloroso é feito com sedação em ambiente
hospitalar né pode causar manchas
descoloração da pele cicatrizes
infecções
e outros
problemas então eu acho que não vale a
pena
não vale a pena essa é minha
opinião agora cada um sabe o que faz né
ou ou pelo menos pensa que sabe o que
faz vamos pra próxima
pergunta Marilda se a concentração de
magnésio alimentar no citrato e magnésio
é 16% então para ser alcançar o mínimo
de 200 mg teríamos que ingerir 150 gram
depende Marilda Porque existe magnésio
na dieta certo o problema se trata em
magnésio é que nessa dose de 1 g por dia
você pode ter
diarreia então muitas vezes você não vai
conseguir fazer a suplementação com c
trato de magnésio porque o intestino vai
soltar mas o raciocínio de você fazer o
cálculo em cima do magnésio alimentar é
correto
certo se você tiver ao vivo eu
posso prestar maiores
esclarecimentos caso não tenha
respondido exatamente que você queria
ouvir Francisco Weber o consumo de
colágeno hidrolizado traz benefícios
reais qual é a
quantidade o verol e o C2 cumprem suas
ões sem existência de matéria prima de
colágeno no
corpo
bem o consumo de colágeno nalizado
primeiro traz benefícios reais a
primeira pergunta sim traz diversos
benefícios existia uma suspeita
anteriormente de que o colágeno
hidrolizado não
seria reaproveitado pelo organismo na
forma de colágeno porque você vai
absorver os peptídeos esses peptídeos
serão re organizados em outras proteínas
e não virão e não virarão
colágeno necessariamente mas isso essa
suspeita já caiu por
terra está comprovado que sim o colágeno
hidrolizado pode dar melhora de firmeza
elasticidade da pele fortalecer unhas e
cabelos auxiliar no tratamento de
flacidez e no envelhecimento precoce da
pele fortalecer articulações e ajudar no
tratamento de doenças como a artrose e
artrite e acelerar a cicatrização de
feridas
tá já a questão que você tá falando
entre o verol e o
C2 se cumpre as funções sem existência
de matéria prima o versol já é dado em
quantidades maiores na faixa de gramas
né de 2 a 5 G até mais você pode usar
até 10 g Em algumas situações vai ficar
caro mas é
possível
então o verisol ele já vai ser um
colágeno completo tem uma eficácia
comprovada estimulação produção de
colágeno no corpo melhorar a saúde da
pele unhas cabelo etc intestino
também agora o caso do colágeno
hidrolizado Tipo dois as doas são bem
menores o C2 né no caso o C2 asas são
bem menores ele atua mais por estímulo
intestinal regulando os processos
inflamatórios que destrói o colágeno das
articulações Então esse daí não fornece
necessariamente matériaprima porque
geralmente a dose é 30 mg é bem baixinha
então a ação do C2 vai ser mais
independente dos níveis de colágeno no
corpo e você pode usar os dois juntos o
C2 com verol potencializando os
efeitos
Carlos ketman na habitualidade ingere-se
suplementos diversos como zinco e outros
ao ingerir adicionalmente por exemplo
zinco
carnosina zinco coloidal ou outro isso
altera concentração do zinco no corpo
sem dúvida qualquer zinco que você for
utilizar vai alterar a
concentração necessita uma reavaliação
de consumo sem dúvida se você usar Zinho
carnosina por exemplo provavelmente você
não vai precisar repor outra forma de
zinco certo então existe situações por
exemplo que a pessoa tá com zinco baixo
no
sangue e aí você quer repor zinco
quelado né zinco glicina Por exemplo
agora se essa pessoa também tiver
indicação de usar Zin carnosina por
causa do estômago aí você pode
simplesmente não dar o zinco glicina e
dá só o Zin com carnosina pode ser
suficiente
Então tem que ser avaliado caso a caso
às vezes só o zinco
carnosina outra forma de zinco pode ser
suficiente você não precisar acrescentar
mais zinco na forma de zinco que
lado no caso dos Inc carnosina ele forma
um complexo molecular que maximiza os
benefícios combin o zinco e carnosina
que vai ter um bom efeito na saúde do
estômago certo então vamos pra
próxima també do Carlos
ketan aparentemente estão havendo novos
caminhos na investigação da demência
fron temporal tentando reduzir a
produção de
pgrn passa a fornecer A grn funcional
sim tá tendo alguns já métodos para
fazer isso na medicina funcional
integrativa existe algo específico para
mitigar ou bloquear o avanço da demência
front temporal eu digo para você Carlos
que esse é um Desafio muito grande
Tá Estão sim havendo os novos caminhos
na investigação da demência front
temporal para reduzir a produção de
pgrn
e fornecer como você falou o grn
funcional em termos de medicina
funcional já volto na questão do
grn a gente pode implementar o protocolo
do Dr de braden né especialmente mudando
a dieta uma dieta que é toflex que uma
dieta cetogênica com vegetal Existe uma
dieta Mind também que pode ser tentada
de qualquer A ideia é você induzir
cetose
leve isso vai ajudar muito na
recuperação do cérebro é mais apropriado
para Alzheimer porque a dieta desculpa
demência front
temporal ela é muito mais difícil de
tratamento é muito importante da dieta
fazer atividade física regular
gerenciamento do estresse o jejum de
pelo menos 12 horas por dia além do
treinamento
cerebral da meditação e do sono né você
fazer o gerenciamento do Sono detox e a
suplementação suplementação é bem
variada bem complexa tem muitas coisas
que podem ser feitas para suplementar
você pode estar vendo os vídeos do canal
sobre a questão do
Alzheimer agora existe para casos
principalmente de demência front
temporal familiar que são ligadas as
mutações de RN novas terapias genéticas
para restaurar os níveis de progranulin
então tem o latz sineme Né que é uma uma
terapia aí gênica que mostrou a
capacidade de elevar os níveis da
progranulin
Então deve ser extremamente caro pode
ajudar a retardar a progressão em caso
de dem fron temporal relacionad a esse
Gene Ok
então eu tenho três casos de fron
temporal Que eu apliquei o protocolo do
recod do Dr de braden porém eu não tive
resultados fantásticos porque essa
doença é muito difícil de
tratar ela funciona melhor com Alzheimer
mesmo do que com a fron temporal e é
muito desafiador PR as famílias fazerem
o protocolo inteiro né todas as mudanças
estilo de vida a maioria tem grande
dificuldade de fazer
isso vamos pra
próxima extrato de adansonia digitata Eu
não conhecia eu tive que dar um estudado
nesse tema aí pode ter usado para
desinflamar próstata sem neoplasia
Marilda depois se você tiver ao vivo me
fala Da onde você tirou o uso desse
agente para próstata porque eu encontrei
algum material sobre isso mas que não
era muito específico para próstata
não o material que eu encontrei falou
muito das propriedades
anti-inflamatórias dessa planta que é a
anô
digitata ela tem efeitos também
antioxidantes tem uns princípios
fitoquímicos que elimina radicais livres
e também alguns estudos de animais
mostrou que tem uma ação de inibição da
inos que é uma enzima que produz aí uma
forma de óxido nítrico Radical Livre né
a inos pró-inflamatória que é a sintase
de óxido nítrico indutível
alguns estratos dessa planta também
tiveram efeitos regenerativos em
testículos de ratos que foram
danificados com
tetracloreto de
carbono e também teve um estudo que
mostrou que teve efeito antitumoral mas
não contra câncer próstata foi contra
células de um carcinoma específico o
carcinoma de erlit que é um carcinoma
mais
raro então pode ser que tenha efeitos
anticancerígenos Mas eu não achei isso
tudo falando de
próstata certo então várias partes dessa
planta folha casca raízes e sementes tem
sido tradicionalmente utilizado na
África que essa planta é de lá para
múltiplos fins terapêuticos medicinais
mais aplicações específicas para
próstata precisam de mais
investigação Então ele pode ter um
potencial sim para ser utilizado na
redução da hiperplasia prostática Mas eu
não conheço estudos específicos então
mais estudos serão para determinar esses
efeitos específicos Tá
bom mas se você achou alguma coisa
relacionada à próstata viu Marilda me
mostra
irci a fosfatase alcalina repetida À
vezes abaixo do mínimo é sempre
característica de hipofosfatemia né ou
ela colocou hip hip fosf mas hi
fosfatemia
ou pode ter outras origens como
autoimunidade sim pode ter origem de
doenças no fígado autoimune sim é
possível ter a condição e não apresentar
oos sintomas sim é possível o que seria
essa condição do ponto de vista da
medicina
integrativa tem Alternativa de reversão
tá primeira coisa é
que essa condição da foss fatas alcalina
baixa Sim pode ser
hipofosfatemia Mas essa é uma doença
Rara Eu parmente nunca peguei é uma
doença genética metabólica que é
caracterizada pela diminuição da
atividade dessa
enzima porém é mais comum que os níveis
baixos de fosfatas alcalina sejam por
outras condições tá por exemplo
desnutrição deficiência de várias
vitaminas e minerais como o zinco e
magnésio doença do fígado que pode ser
doença autoimune doença do rim doença
celíaca anemia a plástica que é um tipo
de anemia mais rara também
hipotiroidismo e os genéticos como eu já
comentei que aí hipos
fantasia então já comentei que as
doenças hepáticas autoimunes pode
provocar isso
e dentro da Medicina funcional
integrativa a abordagem pode envolver o
equilíbrio do sistema de defesa o
sistema
imune manejo da nutrição para dar
suporte à função dos ossos e do fígado e
outras terapias complementares para
otimizar o corpo como
todo é importante monitorar também a
saúde dos ostos e do
fígado
Adriana boa noite por favor dá uma dica
de marca de suplemento bacopa monieri
com a porcentagem alta de
Bacos não consigo encontrar uma marca
geralmente são Americanas tá as marcas
que você vai ver com altos teores de
Bacos Então vamos responder primeiro
isso daí depois fala do
detox
bem Eu achei alguns suplementos com alto
teor de Bacos tem que da
nutricost esse produto da nutricost É
uma opção porque contém 1 g de bacopa
padronizado para 50% de
bacosi então dá uma procurada pelo
bacopa monier
nutricost tem outra marca também chama
naturebell
naturebell também Americana
tem 50% de Bacos Dios e tem uma que tem
na Amazon também que é o Tonic Tonic com
dois is e que mudo no final Tonic com
dois is e q mudo no final Tonic Ultra
strength bacopa tem no pote 14 g de
bacopa também é 50% de
Bacos agora a segunda pergunta é da
desintoxicação clorela pode ser feito em
casa
sim porque o clorela vai ajudar a
eliminar toxinas especialmente Mercúrio
vários outros metais através das fezes é
importante começar com uma dose baixa e
aumentar gradualmente para minimizar o
efeito de rimer né os efeitos colaterais
da eliminação
dos das toxinas e você pode acrescentar
espirulina pectina de maçã tem uma
receita interessante que você faz maçã
cozida para liberar a
pectina depois a coent é muito bom
também e a
zeólita manter bem hidratado ou bem
hidratada fazer dieta saudável né é
muito
importante mas o ideal é que você faça o
detox Com
acompanhamento profissional
certo a
próxima Antônio Renato minha mãe é
diabética Ela queimou o dedo numa panela
não foi muito mas está tão
inchado ela sente dor no braço exercício
físico pode
ajudar pera aí ela queimou o dedo Mas
tem com dor no
braço tá um pouco estranho isso aqui né
Antônia tem que ver algum médico ar isso
aqui viu Antônio exercício físico pode
ajudar mas não sei qual foi o grau dessa
dessa queimadura aqui então não vou nem
dar
palpite
Ok Antônio Renato como saber se o
Diabetes um ou dois glicemia acima de
200 não eh não vai saber se o diabetes é
tipo um ou dois por causa da glicemia ou
por causa da hemoglobina glicada isso aí
você vai saber através
de da relação entre a glicemia e
insulina é a maneira mais fácil de T na
verdade 95% do diabetes é tipo dois tá
só só 5% de diabetes tipo um se a pessoa
não for muito jovem é praticamente
é diabe tipo do se for criança
adolescente ou adulto jovem que você
pensa em diabetes tipo
um uma pessoa pode tratar diabetes
através da cetogênica sim deve sem ir ao
endocrinologista não tem que ir ao
médico não pode pode anunciar
necessariamente endocrinologista mas tem
que ir ao
médico tem que fazer acompanhamento com
o médico a Glicemia reduz com dieta
cetogênica com certeza exercício e jejum
sem dúvida mas fazer sozinho por quê
Antônio Renato não faz sentido né Fazer
Com acompanhamento de um bom
profissional
né bem vamos para as perguntas ao vivo
agora
É verdade que a tintura de espinheira S
tem que ser ingerida longe das refeições
depende
Eliseu porque vai ser melhor absorvido
Mas isso não é necessariamente 100% À
vezes Será que Existe algum alimento sem
carboidrato para melhorar a absorção de
creatina
não sei te dizer
Eliseu a ingerir cinco ovos Cruz de uma
vez eu faço isso uma hora depois de
almoçar já que o ovo cru é líquido e o
almoço é sólido rocina Está correto vai
melhorar sim
a absorção do da proteína se você
ingerir fora de uma refeição Mas isso
não é
necessariamente tão essencial fazer tá
eu faria até duas ou TR horas depois tá
E nem faria uma hora depois se a
intenção aumentar absorção de da dos
aminoácidos absorção e
processamento não é bom deitar logo após
comer devido à possibilidade de
refluxo vai depender tem gente que não
tem refluxo nenhum vai depender da
pessoa né agora se você não quer ter
refluxo e ten a predisposição e quer
cilar depois do almoço você fique numa
posição mais mais assim Sentada né cile
numa poltrona ou num sofá que você fique
com a cabeça mais
elevada açúcar mas Calvo da floril eu
acho que você não entendeu Você não
entendeu que nós conversamos
o açúcar de modo geral para qualquer
coisa fermentada é usada para a
proliferação das bactérias que estão
fermentando ali
tá agora o açúcar não é adicionado para
a pessoa ingerir o açúcar em si mas para
usar como fonte de alimento das
bactérias
a questão do filtro do clor É porque
quando
você aumenta a temperatura da água ela
vira vapor né geralmente esse vapor tem
cloro se puder usar o
o filtro de cloro é bem melhor
assim
eu não entendi essa pergunta tanto
ômega3 ele tem um efeito anticoagulante
sim doses
altas o K2 geralmente ele não provoca
coágulos porque ele tem 1/4 da potência
do k1 na dose normal de K2 você não vai
ter problema de coágulo com k com
K2
depende de cada pessoa
Eliseu na questão do magnésio treonato é
que o treonato tem molécula muito grande
para você usar essa como a única fonte
de magnésio você tem que ingerir muita
quantidade mesmo de volume por causa do
do tamanho da molécula do treonato tanto
que se você for ver os suplementos que
tem no exterior eles são na faixa até de
gramas de 500 mg até 1 g por conta da
questão do tamanho do
treonato sim o já falei várias ocasiões
que a micolamina é uma vitamina de
depósito ela ela é a única vitamina do
Complexo B que é de depósito então ela
vai ser armazenada sim
não tem problema porque muitas injeções
Inclusive tem mais ou menos essa dose aí
que você tá
colocando tem algumas vitaminas do
complexo B que elas são consumidas se
você Tom uma dose alta de uma vitamina
específica tá por exemplo se você tá uma
B12 você acaba consumindo o metilfolato
essa que é a questão quando você tá T
tomando uma dose alta de uma vitamina do
Complexo B é conveniente você repor as
outras vitaminas do complexo
B adolescente 15 anos pode usar beberina
sem problemas pode usar sim thgo a não
ser que tenha algum efeito
colateral PCA pode usar sim pode pode
usar páprica sim mas alguma situação
específica
não é que o vírus fica mais forte Eliseu
é que o vírus ele sai da área
eh normal dele uma uma área limitada uma
uma área delimitada ali que o vírus
convive e entra em contato com outras
ecossistemas que não são os originais aí
esse vírus pode sofrer mutações
e contaminar outros organismos que não
são os que são do habitate
dele essa história da carne vermelha
ninguém tem certeza
Eliseu Por precaução a maioria dos
médicos especialistas falam para que
você coma eh duas vezes semana porque
não existe uma certeza absoluta que a
carne vem vermelha não tem problemas tá
os estudos da carne vermelha é mais de
carne processada ou de carne
esturricada que gera aqueles corpos de
glicação
avançado e outras substâncias químicas
que também são prejudiciais é por isso
que por precaução todo mundo fala de
comer carne vermelha poucas vezes por
semana mas isso não é
certeza
eh Eu já li recentemente uma história
falando que essc os copos da stany tá
liberando chumbo viu É melhor evitar
esses
copos por causa da liberação de
chumbo eu não entendi que que que que é
250.000 por ano
Carlos não é porque o alfa lipoico ele
pode doer o estômago tá por isso que se
recomenda usar gastroresistente
mas não é que tem que ser só a gast
resistente de
nada sim carvão vegetal É bem
interessante para diarreias agudas por
intoxicação
alimentar bem não sei o que você quer
dizer com o livro atualizado tá o o
último livro lançado foram foi esse aqui
ó deixa eu
mostrar
e é dos pacientes né os primeiros
curados né
pela vamos achar
aqui cadê o que foi lançado esse ano tá
aqui deixa eu mostrar aqui deixa eu
parar de compartilhar essa tela aqui
e
vou
[Música]
mostrar então um livro
recente É esse aqui ou esse azulzinho ó
the first
survivors of
alzheimers How patients recover Life and
Hope agora eu tô vendo
aqui que eles lançaram uma atualização
do End of alheim program esse livro aqui
não é o mais
recente mas tá com data de 2022 deve ser
out edição
já vamos ver
aqui esse livro eu li mas eu acho que
não foi a versão de
22 bem vamos para as próximas
aqui toda vez que uma pessoa solta gás
com cheiro significa que o fungo Cândida
não tem tantas coisas que podem produzir
cheiro metano por exemplo não é a
cândida que produz
metano BA Bas que formam metano não tem
nada a ver com câes isso
não existe Kefir de leite de coco Aí sim
é um alimento fermentado e É
probiótico sim é melhor que você utilize
coração de galinha caipira né se você
puder Ah você tá falando do tratamento
não é dale breads Carl você tá falando
falando
da do médico lá brasileiro que tá na
Flórida vendendo um tratamento de
hipertermia né o
doutor como é que é mesmo esqueci o nome
dele
agora o
doutor caramba fugiu agora Mark Mark
acho que é
Mark esqueci agora daqui a pouco eu
lembro mas não é de m temporal é para el
ele Ele oferece PR Alzheimer e para
parkson se eu não me engano talvez
esteja fazendo para fron temporal
também os orgonites pros efeitos nocivos
da radiação funciona ou é
balela não tenho certeza Adriana eu
tenho alguns orgonites que eu ganhe de
presente mas eu eu tenho um pouco de
receio de não funcionar Adriana
sinceramente sim aprovo É bem
interessante não conheço Eliseu
masterclass de sono não
conheço bem pessoal já tem quase 1 hora
de Live eu vou encerrar
tá obrigado por vocês terem comparecido
hoje eu acho que muita gente fez
pergunta na no questionário não
comparecer ao vivo Então vai ter que
assistir depois gravado um abraço para
vocês até a próxima semana fique com
Deus